you think of the flavor and the texture
of avocado
rich phenomenal i want to make it a
little bit more vibrant
black sesame seeds a nice pinch of chili
flakes
i quite like it hot a touch of salt
and a touch of pepper so that nice dry
combination of the lemon zest
black sesame seeds and the heat the
chili this is
light healthy quick but so tasty
sourdough bread three nice chunky
thick slices open them up lightly season
them
little touch of olive oil brings the
whole crust to life
rub all that seasoning in but you can
use
too bad you can use a baguette but the
richness from the sourdough with the
silky creaminess of avocado
is mind-blowing and then get the grill
up to temperature
and push these down go the extra mile
we've all put bread
in a toaster of a difference of grilling
the bread this way
is extraordinary that nice smoky
charcoal flavor
off with the gas beautiful now the
avocado
you've got to treat them with love
respect press on the end here
and if your thumb softens you can tell
that avocado's ripe
never press here you just end up
bruising it slice down
until you feel that stone in the middle
and then just
roll around and then it's just a little
gentle twist
off stone
and out cut them into quarters the back
of your knife
peel back that skin if the avocado is
nice and ripe
it should just all fall away slice
just take your quarters fan them out and
push them into the bread
the ripe of the avocado the better the
flavor but look for ones free from soft
spots and blemishes which can suggest
bruising
get your lemon squeeze
that will stop the avocado from
discoloring and then get your
crunch ready to go on top
sprinkle a very generous light way
got the fragrance from the lemon zest
the crunch from the sesame seed
the heat that little chili flake which
just wakes up
that avocado they look
expensive that for me is a delicious
light start to the day
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
every time i put a healthy recipe
together
a healthy dish it needs a bit of a treat
so this is a lovely
stunning get up and go fresh granola
first thing in the morning
the treat here is in that little baby
honey
so that sweetens it so just start off
with 200ml
of delicious honey into a pan just to
warm up
in she goes now i know these are
a chef's favorite but it makes all the
difference
especially for breakfast a fresh
vanilla pod and i think of the way that
i use herbs to add
flavor to soups and salads i'd like to
think vanilla does exactly the same
scrape out all those wonderful seeds in
now the staple of the granola
is the oats
[Music]
next puff rice delicious
crunchy but light
and fluffy next add wheat bran and your
seeds
pumpkin sunflower and linseed
and then almonds incredible
that nice heavy weight from the nut
bunch
now bring the honey to the boil
slowly drizzle that amazing honey
in give that a really good mix
coat the granola with the hot honey just
slowly churn it
using the outside of the bowl
you can see it just getting nice and
sticky
once the granola is completely coated in
honey it's ready to bake
now spread the mix on baking paper i'm
gonna season it
lightly with a touch of salt on top
the salt throughout dries up
the oats and the honey will roast color
and glaze the granola
nice into the oven for 25 to 30 minutes
[Music]
10 minutes into the cooking simply run a
spoon across the top to turn the mix
and ensure it's crunchy all over smell
that light
roast look at the color honestly
look it's crispy it's delicious
now i'm gonna tart it up and put some
lovely dried cranberries
that just gives us chewy sweet flavor
delicious and then finally these
beautiful berries goji berries
goji berries are high in antioxidants
and have been eaten china for centuries
for their healing properties
but you can add any dried fruit you like
the cranberry
and the goji berries gives it that nice
chewy rich texture
to the granola now this is
the best way to store it it looks
incredible
really incredible look at that
that eat well stay well
right milk
my homemade crunchy granola it looks
good tastes good
and it's packed with healthy grains
superfood berries and seeds
it's incredibly good for you too a
breakfast for champions
start off with a chili now
give it a little rub so
you can hear those seeds being released
get your knife and come all the way down
turn it over and just slice it into four
and then
finely chop that chili i want this salad
slightly hot so i'm gonna use all the
chili but a half the seeds
the seeds are where the heat is so the
less you use
the milder your dish nicely chopped
next one of my favorite pastes tamarind
paste
this is quite tart quite sour but it's a
wonderful compliment to the sweetness of
the fruit and it goes brilliantly well
with the chilli
palm sugar and this is where it sweetens
up
the dressing because it enriches it then
the zest
and the juice of the lime cut it into
quarters
and then twist the lime to maximize
and all that juice out now to finish
that dressing off
some toasted peanuts
get the pan nice and hot
a little touch of salt that'll help dry
roast the peanuts even quicker
make sure you get a really nice dark
color on those peanuts
because it will really transform that
dressing to crush your roasted nuts the
mess free way
simply wrap them in a clean cloth and
use a rolling pin
or a pan to bash them crush
that's the hard bit done now
for the fruit and here's an easy way to
prep a pineapple
pineapple take off the top
take off the bottom
and stand it up use the corner of your
knife and follow down
basically like shaving the pineapple
don't worry about these little spikes
there the secret behind doing it this
way
is not losing half the pineapple there's
nothing wrong with a few brown bits
it's all good fiber slice the pineapple
in half
and then slice down each quarter
slice across and chop
delicious pineapple chunks
next apples and pears diced then to give
a lovely fresh light note
the seeded cucumber i don't want the
seeds in the fruit salad
the cucumber seeds will make it very
watery and dilute the strength of that
wonderful chili in there
cucumber in with some sweetness
delicious mango just slice it nicely
get your dressing and just drizzle that
over the fruit salad
in secret of a good fruit salad
is not drowning in the dressing but
really make sure that you've got that
nice coating on all
the fruits don't worry about just having
for breakfast because this is the kind
of tangy fruit salad you can have
for lunch a healthy snack in the
afternoon but it transforms
a traditional fruit salad into something
really delicious
spicy fruit salad with a kick of chili
trust me it's an incredible breakfast
and a guaranteed pick me up in the
morning